♪ ("EL DESEO"
BY JANET SHERBOURNE PLAYS) ♪
-What are you doing?
-I think I'm eating an apple.
Okay. I'm worried you're not
taking this seriously.
You're blithely
eating an apple here.
There's no other way
to eat an apple but blithely.
-Yeah, but I need--
-That's how apples are eaten.
How do you serve eggs
without toast?
You can't serve the eggs
without the toast.
You are like a president
in the 18th century
on the back of a train saying,
"And there will always be
toast with eggs."
I think you can introduce me
sort of as a renaissance man.
A guy who speaks six languages.
You wanna impress people
with lies?
Well,
how else do you impress them?
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪